flu season in the United States and
Europe is approaching many people will
roll up their sleeves for the jab some
will be protected some will suffer sure
the numbers are pretty good at best
about 60% of people who get the shot
will dodge the flu
at worst only 10% will be protected the
flu virus constantly mutates which
forces vaccine manufacturers to
reformulate it every year it takes about
seven months to make the vaccine so
different strains pop up by the time
it's ready which is the long-standing
explanation of why the vaccine often
fails but it's more complicated in that
and something can be done about it why
doesn't the flu vaccine always work eggs
the form of the virus used in the flu
vaccine is actually grown inside of
chicken eggs researchers discovered that
mutations in the virus occur during this
growth often in regions important to
triggering immune responses and this can
undermine the vaccines ability to
protect people
ferrets ferrets are the most popular
animal model for human influenza the
traditional way to select a strain for
the vaccine involves injecting ferrets
with an influenza virus used to make a
vaccine strain harvesting the antibodies
and then mixing them with a virus
isolated from a human who recently had
influenza if the antibodies don't stop
the virus the vaccine strain has changed
aside from the fact that ferrets aren't
humans antibodies aren't viral sequences
ghosts of flus past we repeatedly get
flu vaccines and are naturally exposed
to the virus in the wild and it turns
out that our first exposure in our lives
oddly sets the table for all flu
reactions after this dizzyingly complex
history makes predicting the impact of a
flu vaccine in an individual
staggeringly difficult ok so what can we
do about it
stop growing it in eggs start using
genetically engineered viral proteins
stop relying so heavily on ferrets and
more purposefully factoring viral
sequence data learn more about the
immune responses linked to protection
and how to outwit the original exposure
incorporate parts of the virus that
rarely mutate ideally creating a
universal shot that targets all strains
and lasts for a lifetime but for now
experts say the flu vaccine even given
its limits can still save lives and
spare suffering for many people
especially anyone with a compromised
immune system and the elderly
[Music]